foreign
[Music]
Congressional candidate Rashida tlaib a
Democrat from Michigan celebrated her
recent primary Victory with several
anti-israel tweets including one that
read my roots as a Palestinian American
are strong and important
the truth about those roots however
could surprise even slaib as before the
1960s there were no Palestinian people
as I show in my new book the history of
jihad from Muhammad to Isis the
Palestinians were invented as a
propaganda weapon against Israel
in 1948 the nascent state of Israel
defeated forces from Egypt Iraq Syria
transjordan Lebanon Saudi Arabia and
Yemen that had been determined to
destroy it utterly the Jihad against it
continued but it held firm defeating
Egypt Iraq Syria Jordan and Lebanon
again in the Six-Day War in 1967 and
Egypt and Syria yet again in the 1973
Yom Kippur War
in winning these victories against
enormous odds Israel won the admiration
of the Free World leading to the largest
scale and most audacious application in
Islamic history of Muhammad's dictum war
is deceit
in order to destroy the impression of
the tiny Jewish State facing enormous
Muslim Arab foes and prevailing the
Soviet KGB the Soviet committee for
State security developed the fiction of
an even smaller people the Palestinians
menaced by a well-oiled and ruthless
Israeli War Machine
in ad-134 the Romans had expelled the
Jews from Judea after the bar kokba
revolt and renamed the region Palestine
the Romans plucked this name from the
Bible it was the name of the Israelites
ancient enemies the Philistines but
never did the term Palestinian refer to
anything but a region not to a people or
an ethnicity
in the 1960s however the KGB and the
nephew of the Mufti of Jerusalem
hajamina husseini who collaborated with
the Nazis during World War II yeser
Arafat created both these allegedly
oppressed people and the instrument of
their freedom the Palestine Liberation
Organization or PLO
Eon mihai pasepa who had served as
acting chief of Cold War era communist
Romania Spy Service later revealed what
happened he said the PLO was dreamed up
by the KGB which had a penchant for
Liberation organizations there was the
National Liberation Army of Bolivia
created by the KGB in 1964 with help
from Ernesto Che Guevara the KGB also
created the Democratic front for the
liberation of Palestine which carried
out numerous bombing attacks in 1964 the
first PLO Council consisting of 422
Palestinian Representatives hand-picked
by the KGB approved the Palestinian
national Charter a document that had
been drafted in Moscow the Palestinian
national Covenant and the Palestinian
Constitution were also born in Moscow
with the help of Ahmed shukairi a KGB
influence agent who became the first PLO
chairman
for Arafat to head the PLO he had to be
a Palestinian himself pasepa explained
Arafat was an Egyptian Bourgeois turned
into a devoted Marxist by KGB foreign
intelligence the KGB had trained him at
its balashika Special Operations School
East of Moscow and in the mid-1960s
decided to groom him as the future PLO
leader first the KGB destroyed the
official records of arafat's birth in
Cairo and replaced them with fictitious
documents saying that he had been born
in Jerusalem and was therefore a
Palestinian by birth
Arafat may have been a Marxist at least
at first but he and his Soviet handlers
made copious use of Islamic
anti-Semitism KGB Chief Yuri andropov
noted the Islamic world was awaiting
petri dish in which we could nurture a
virulent strain of America hatred grown
from the bacterium of marxist leninist
thought Islamic anti-Semitism ran deep
we had only to keep repeating our themes
that the United States and Israel were
fascist Imperial Zionist countries
bankrolled by Rich Jews
Islam was obsessed with preventing the
infidel's occupation of its territory
and it would be highly receptive to our
characterization of the U.S Congress as
a rapacious Zionist body aiming to turn
the world into a Jewish fiefdom
PLO executive committee member Zakir
musane explains the strategy more fully
in a 1977 interview with the Dutch
newspaper truo
the Palestinian people he said does not
exist the creation of a Palestinian
state is only a means for continuing our
struggle against the state of Israel for
our Arab Unity in reality today there is
no difference between jordanians
Palestinians syrians and Lebanese only
for political and tactical reasons do we
speak today about the existence of a
Palestinian people since Arab national
interests demand that we posit the
existence of a distinct Palestinian
people to oppose Zionism for technical
reasons Jordan which is a sovereign
state with defined borders cannot raise
claims to Haifa and yaffa while as a
Palestinian I can undoubtedly demand
Haifa yaffa birshiva and Jerusalem
however the moment we Proclaim our right
to all of Palestine we will not wait
even a minute to unite Palestine and
Jordan
once the people had been created their
desire for peace could be easily
fabricated as well Romanian dictator
Nicolet chachescu tutored Arafat in how
to play the West like a fiddle pasepa
recounted in March 1978 I secretly
brought Arafat to Bucharest for final
instructions on how to behave in
Washington you simply have to keep on
pretending that you'll break with
terrorism and that you'll recognize
Israel over and over and over chaucesku
told Arafat chachescu was euphoric over
the prospect that both Arafat and he
might be able to snag a Nobel Peace
Prize with their fake displays of the
Olive Branch
chaucescu failed to get his Nobel Peace
Prize but in 1994 Arafat got his all
because he continued to play the role
that had been given him to Perfection he
had transformed his terrorist PLO into a
government in Exile the Palestinian
Authority Always pretending to call a
halt to Palestinian terrorism while
letting it continue unabated
two years after signing the Oslo Accords
the number of Israelis killed by
Palestinian terrorists had risen by 73
percent
this strategy continued to work
beautifully through U.S brokered peace
process after peace process from the
1978 Camp David Accords into the
presidency of Barack Obama and Beyond
with no end in sight
Western authorities never seemed to
ponder why so many attempts to achieve a
negotiated peace between Israel and the
Palestinians whose historical existence
Everybody by now takes for granted have
all failed the answer of course lies in
the Islamic doctrine of jihad drive them
out from where they drove you out as a
command that contains no mitigation and
accepts none
I'm Robert Spencer Shulman fellow for
the David Horowitz Freedom Center and
director of jihad watch this video has
been brought to you by the center for
security policy
[Music]